well welcome everybody today is a Friday
show sort of I know it's Wednesday but
it's our last show for the week because
of the upcoming Thanksgiving holiday and
sort of a Friday show in format we'll be
taking a few live calls later but not
quite as many as we normally would on
Friday I do have a bunch of stories I
want to talk about and I want to start
with what we all knew was only going to
be a matter of time right-wing media is
now blaming the victims of the Club Q
shooting in Colorado you know I didn't
cover this shooting already
and I got a couple emails asking why and
I'm going to delve into it more next
week actually but when these shootings
happen first of all I will often wait a
couple of days because I want to get the
information right and these shootings
are so common I mean just look at
gunviolencearchive.org oftentimes
there's not that much more to say now
this one had a particularly nefarious
element to it in that it does appear
that the target was chosen because of
anti-lgbt sentiment and because of now
the use of the term groomer by the right
which is basically applied uh as a a
typically sexually predatory or
otherwise predatory term to everything
from drag shows to just a gay couple
that wants to adopt a kid they are now
using that framing to do some victim
blaming and I'm going to play a couple
of examples for you here is one from
Tucker Carlson where his guest Jamie
Mitchell who is the founder of an
organization called gays against
groomers
helps Tucker Carlson say listen this is
going to continue until we end gender
affirming care listen to these
disgusting people
didn't have to be said that what is
anti-lgbtq that these people need to
understand and what is putting our
community in great danger is uh you know
claiming that all of us support this and
just associating all of us with this
um you know saying that groomer is an
anti-lgbtq slur that is doing
irreparable damage to us uh as a whole
and is putting a really large Target on
our backs and unfortunately you know the
tragedy that happened in Colorado
Springs the other night uh you know it
was expected and predictable
um we all within gays against rumors saw
this coming from a mile away and sadly I
don't think it's going to stop until we
uh end this evil agenda that is
attacking children now by evil agenda
she's referring to gender affirming care
which we've already talked about in
detail it is not some wild heretical
thing it is actually something based in
years and years now of study and they
want to frame it as basically pervert
doing things to your kids so so saying
listen this is going to keep happening
until we stop gender affirming care
they're not even hiding it at this point
there's no consequences for them at
least not thus far so why would they
stop they wouldn't here is another
example this is Matt Walsh Matt Walsh
we've talked about him before he's
become very known among right-wing
cultural circles and Social Circles as
the guy who really hammers on this
scourge of uh transgender gender
affirming care Etc
here he is doing another version of look
what you made me do to you that's a
classic from abusers why do you keep
making me punch you in the face family
friendly drag shows quote-unquote have
two purposes
one from the drag queens perspective is
to satisfy their fetish for
cross-dressing in front of children
the other on a more macro level is to
indoctrinate children into queer Theory
to put it simply
the point of drag queen Story Hour and
the child the the supposed
family-friendly drag shows is to turn
your children queer that is the goal
and whenever you say that by the way
consider how insane that is consider how
absurd that is given the reality of what
we know about sexual orientation turn
your children queer this is It's it
seems this guy was in diapers when that
talking point was already being debunked
just said right there's me clip on me
any matters hello everybody on Twitter
um
the people who invented it stated
explicitly that that is the point to
help children live clearly that's their
quote
and the thing about the left is that
what they believe and what they do
all of it is so horrifying so perverse
so degraded that if you just quote them
then you somehow sound like the crazy
one if you quote what they are saying it
makes it sounds crazy just to say it out
loud because it's so horrifying
yet it's true
and this is the reason the left cares so
much about this and they defend it so
vigorously because according to the last
think about this
according to the left
the drag queen child combination has
become dangerous they say it's a
lightning rod for violent backlash
right that's what they said and it's
greatly exaggerated of course mostly
it's invented out of whole cloth
actually but
but even by their version of events
if it's causing this much chaos and
violence
why do you insist on continuing to do it
right if according to you it's like
putting people's lives at risk
if if the effort to have men
cross-dressed in front of children is
putting people's lives at risk why are
you still doing it is it that important
to you
now as always they try to flip the
burden around on us
they demand that we explain why we
object to children being exposed to drag
queens but of course it's not about
objection it's about violence and this
is of course outrageous right listen if
the thing you're doing is angering
lunatic so much that they shoot at you
just stop doing the thing isn't that
exactly the type of speech they say
shouldn't be curtailed by threats of
violence it doesn't make any sense and
these folks this one from day one had a
tinge to it where we knew they were
going to blame the victims if you just
stop doing this crazy stuff then people
wouldn't go and start shooting you up
blame the victims blame that they often
do it with rape and they're doing it
here hey you know
if you're wondering what happened to all
the crime since November 8th you're
actually bringing up a very interesting
question Fox news stories about violent
crime are down 50 percent since the
November 8th midterm election there's a
very good research piece from Media
Matters Fox's coverage of violent crime
dropped after the midterms weekday
violent crime segments decreased by 50
percent in the week of the election
compared to the weekly average since
Labor Day are any of us surprised in
fact Fox News decreased stories about
violent crime 63 percent
Media Matters has the details this is
not unique I assure you to Fox News we
all knew in the lead up to the November
8th midterms that there's stories about
violent crime which of course ignore
that by the way stories about violent
crime in what they call Democrat cities
not only ignore the facts of for example
on a crime rate basis Oklahoma is more
dangerous than New York State and on a
crime rate basis both property and
violent crime Oklahoma City is more
dangerous than New York City remember
rates a lot more people live in New York
City aside from the fact that it's an
absurd narrative
and that most cities in general are run
by democrats because more Democrats tend
to live in cities we also know that it's
just a ploy and I want to remind you I'm
going to give you other examples all of
which I have previously covered because
they do this all the time in 2014 it was
Ebola remember the guy who went ebolaing
at Brooklyn Bowl and at the time I was
like at Brooklyn Bowl the day after and
I was worried that I get Ebola what's
going on anyway 2014. we knew leading up
to the midterms that Ebola was being
used by people like Rand Paul stands out
and many others just to criticize Barack
Obama that's all that it was they just
wanted to criticize Obama Obama and even
though there were like
four cases
and the one person that died got Ebola
outside of the country if I recall I
mean it was crazy
and the day after the 2014 midterms no
more talk about ebola and it never came
back they never talked about it again
another example this is a classic the
migrant Caravan coverage this one was in
2018 leading up to the 2018 midterms
under Donald Trump the migrant Caravans
are on the way they're coming they're
coming here and we know that migrant
Caravans tell us oh there's an election
coming up and of course as is reported
here migrant Caravan coverage plummeted
after the midterms and indeed it did and
also a piece from Vox Fox News barely
mentions Caravan first morning after
midterms Fox and Friends had been just
ranting and ranting and ranting about
Caravans day after the midterms they
quite literally still have the election
results up on the screen this was the
date this was November
6th or 7th 2018 when whenever
um and they barely talk about it we know
the story we know exactly what they do
it's very clear at this point remember
not to follow it and ask yourselves the
question not fall for it ask yourself
the question is this getting coverage
because it's important is this getting
coverage because it's accurate or is
this getting coverage because it serves
a political goal or a media goal which
can often be creating fear and
titillating and scaring viewers if you
ask those questions you figure these out
pretty quickly Donald Trump is Going
Bonkers because the Supreme Court has
said this is it your tax returns are
going to the house committee that is
investigating you the Supreme Court has
said that is it a Newsweek reporting
Donald Trump's tax returns at the mercy
of leakers and indeed as I've told you
before
if and when Trump's taxes get to that
house committee
a lot of different people on that
committee could leak the taxes
I believe the taxes will leak I'm not
advocating for a leak I'm not
encouraging criminality I'm merely
giving you my prediction my prediction
is that these documents are of such
interest
that they will leak once they are in the
hands of that house committee and indeed
Newsweek reports the Supreme Court
decision to allow Donald Trump's tax
returns to be handed over to a house
committee will not result in the former
president's Financial records becoming
public
unless there is a leak in a ruling
Tuesday Supreme Court Justices rejected
Trump's attempt to block a lower court
decision to Grant the
democratic-controlled Ways and Means
Committee access to the IRS records now
interestingly with the house Taking Over
Control in January there is a sort of
time as of the essence element to this
but Trump is Going Bonkers posting to
his platform truth social truth
essential quote why would anybody be
surprised that the Supreme Court has
ruled against me they always do
it is unprecedented to be handing over
tax returns and it creates terrible
precedent for future presidents has Joe
Biden paid taxes on all the money he
made illegally from Hunter and Beyond
the Supreme Court has lost its honor
Prestige and standing by the way a third
of the Supreme Court is people Trump
picked and has become nothing more than
a political body with our Capital C
country paying the price they refused to
even look at the election hoax of 2020
shame on them
I would expect
that Trump's taxes will leak if the
house Ways and Means Committee gets them
particularly if it gets them with such
little time to investigate before
Republicans Take Over Control of the
house that's a prediction let me know
what you think leave a comment if you're
watching on YouTube and make sure you're
subscribed at youtube.com this is new
YouTube is revamping everything okay
youtube.com slash at symbol the David
packman show youtube.com at symbol the
davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
remember that the David packman show is
counting on you to sign up at
joinpakman.com if you'd like to support
the work that we do of course we produce
the show every day free for everybody to
listen to or to watch it is subsidized
by about one percent of our audience
that supports us through the membership
program at joinpakman.com you can sign
up and use the coupon code 24 starts now
the second woman
who was urged by Herschel Walker to get
an abortion has now come forward to
explain that Herschel Walker threatened
suicide after impregnating her now it's
so hard to keep track of this you might
remember there was the first woman who
said Herschel Walker urged me to have an
abortion and I got it and then he urged
me to have another abortion and I
refused and then we had a kid that's
woman number one
then we had woman number two represented
by attorney Gloria Allred woman number
two said he urged me to have an abortion
and I did it I believe that this woman
that we were talking about today is
woman number two
although the reporting is a little
unclear and this may be a third woman
but I'm pretty sure it's that second
woman listen to this 1893 93 she learned
that Mr Walker had impregnated her
my client did not want to have an
abortion
when she told Mr Walker about the
pregnancy he spoke about disappearing
and he quote afterlife end quote and
made her believe
that he might commit suicide can you
imagine this level of manipulation
he also claimed that if she gave birth
both our client and their child would be
in danger
Jane Doe stated that she felt pressured
by Mr Walker's threats and went alone to
the abortion clinic
to have the procedure
but she left crying because she did not
want to go through with it
after she told Mr Walker that she did
not have the abortion
she stated that the next day Mr Walker
drove her in his car to the abortion
clinic to ensure that she had the
abortion
that she did not want to have Wilson
I'm sure
there are more details to all of these
stories and also stories we haven't
heard at the end of the day there are
many reasons not to vote for Herschel
Walker his extreme personal hypocrisy on
a lot of these political issues is one
reason his complete lack of morals is
another reason
his inability to explain what his
policies would be is another reason his
lack of understanding of policy is
another reason and also the fact that
Raphael Warnock is a pretty damn good
Senator there is already someone doing
that job who is doing a pretty good job
everyone must vote on December 6th or
during early voting if you live in
Georgia we will be live with those
results and just the situation gets more
disgusting just about every day
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on
a on this very powerful erection yes but
Herschel Walker flanked last night on
Fox news by Senator Lindsey Graham and
Senator Ted Cruz
said that what's happening in Georgia
this erection is about the people
well first of all this election is more
than Herschel Walker this direction is
about the people
want to hear it one more time
well first of all this election is more
than Herschel Walker this direction is
about the people yeah Ted Cruz visibly
moving his eyes and then trying to play
it cool listen I don't really have much
else to say about this for a guy who
impregnated so many women and then urged
them to get abortions this is quite the
Freudian slip vote Raphael Warnock on
December 6th I want to look at a couple
clips from a recent episode of the
Stephen Bannon program Stephen Bannon
interviewed a guy almost as ubiquitous
as Cher or Madonna a guy we know of as
pillow of course I'm talking about my
pillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell Mike
Lindell makes it clear he is willing to
lose everything over the machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines listen to this it is surreal
and Beyond parody at this point
feel since you've had your business
destroyed your life destroyed your
employees destroyed you're not in
Walmart you're not anywhere because of
your Crusade about these machines sir
well Steve it doesn't matter if I if it
takes me to lose everything I want to
save our country
how does that make he was willing to
lose everything
he told me during our interview that
he's in about 30 million dollars so far
to this election nonsense still no proof
from him about any of his claims and by
the way one other funny note about this
interview is about Twitter
Mike Lindell is angry that even though
all sorts of right-wingers and spreaders
of lies about the election have been
unbanned from Twitter since Elon Musk
purchased it he hasn't and he's angry my
my shout out to uh Elon Musk would be
yeah you know if your son should be a
new platform of uh of free speech yeah
um but yet you're gonna carve out the
guys that talk about our election crimes
and our election Integrity
um I don't think it's that freeze Steve
I think it's I I think I would like to
do a shout out to Elon Musk right now
hey check out the evidence I was banned
because uh I was telling the truth and
that's that's uh that's disgusting and
uh to be one of the few people that's
still hang on hang on
they have not they have not reached out
to you and asked you for the evidence
you had and ask you yeah Elon is going
to personally decide whether to unban
pillow after looking at his supposed
evidence which he's never revealed to
anyone ever every time I interview
pillow he tells me he'll send me the
evidence he never does he told me he
would send me pillows he never did one
other funny note on this
after pillow airs his grievances about
not being unbanned Bannon actually says
I don't even want to be on Twitter
because it's uh funded by the Chinese
Communist party I have no interest in
being on Twitter it would never be on
Twitter because it is financed by the
Chinese Communist party and Elon Musk
got a comfort and prove to people that
it's not Tesla the whole deal stinks to
high heaven yeah it all stinks to Steve
Bannon listen I believe we're coming to
the end of the pillow Arc thankfully in
many ways I still am unsure
is pillow a grifter or is he a victim of
the grift I can't tell I used to ask is
he does he believe the stuff he says or
doesn't he I believe he believes the
stuff he says that seems really clear to
me at this point the next question is is
he one of those perpetuating the scam or
has he simply fallen for it I believe he
believes it either way but I can't tell
whether he is a primary node or a
reactive node let me know what you think
and we'll have all these clips on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's go
to the phones a couple of days early we
are off on Thursday and Friday for
Thanksgiving so we are taking calls
today we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord and we're working through some
technical issues and let's see if we can
do it let's go first to Toby from North
Carolina Toby if you can hear me and if
you're unmuted let me know what's on
your mind today
uh hi David can you hear me I can hear
you fine
hi so um recently with the
um shooting in Colorado
um at what point do you think we should
start holding people
um accountable for
um the hateful rhetoric surrounding uh
gay people and trans people and other
marginalized groups because it seems
like you could draw a pretty direct line
between uh violence and um these
people's rhetoric well listen morally
speaking I think it's pretty clear that
there is already what we might call
responsibility and in fact we did a
segment
um earlier about how they're going
pretty quickly to the victim blaming and
saying listen these groomers should
expect what's going on because of gender
affirming care and so on and so forth so
morally speaking we're already there
legally speaking we're really kind of
talking about a type of stochastic
terrorism
and it we've talked before about how it
is really difficult to hold people
legally responsible when you have an
audience of you know 5 million and you
target some individual or a group and
then one person goes and does something
I'm not saying anyone specifically said
go and do this at this particular place
but when someone goes and does something
legally speaking you're not really going
to be able to hold them accountable
based on current law and I don't even
know exactly what a better law would
look like I'm just not weighing in but I
just don't think you're really going to
be able to
all right that's all I got thank you all
right Toby from North Carolina thank you
very much appreciate hearing from you
let's go next to Steve from the San
Francisco Bay Area Steve welcome what's
on your mind today
hey David nice to talk to you again um I
was trying to think about
um how we can get more uh taxes out of
Corporations you know because
historically we're at a pretty low rate
right now
um and we don't also want to
disincentivize them and you know send
them away I don't know if that's a real
argument but anyways I was thinking
about an idea where perhaps there was
some sort of sliding scale as far as the
tax rate relative to a corporation's
profit what do you think about that
you're basically just talking about a
progressive bracketed system for
corporations
yeah basically like certain industries
of course have very high profit margins
like um like the beauty industry and
things like that
um others not so much but I'm I'm saying
like hey if you're making huge multiples
of your your Revenue you know maybe you
have a higher tax rate than a company
that's making a smaller tax or uh I
don't know that I would do it by
industry but I actually think there's
lower hanging fruit and this is
something that a lot of democratic
lawmakers have tried to go for which is
we need to have a minimum tax for
corporations and this has been part of a
number of different proposals and to be
honest I don't remember if it's part of
what Biden wants to do the the idea is
you can't deduct your way all the way
down to zero taxes the way some
corporations have done and part of what
you do is you have to eliminate certain
mechanisms uh and it's sort of beyond
the scope of this particular call but
you know before we go look into
progressive tax rates for corporations
there are very profitable corporations
that pay literally zero or have a
negative tax rate that needs to be
eliminated with something equivalent to
the alternative minimum tax for
businesses
oh yeah for sure uh you know places like
Amazon are famous for that kind of thing
absolutely yeah that's a very good
solution and I I can get behind that all
right Steve well thank you everything
good in the Bay Area
uh yeah it's uh nice and about 65 today
enjoying the California weather oh
that's a great temperature it's hard to
beat 65 in my book
yeah all right Steve thank you
okay thanks all right the San Francisco
Bay Area always great to check in let's
go to Tim from Binghamton Tim welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
thank you David
um can you hear me okay I can hear you
fine
awesome so I'm a teacher I've uh called
in before a long time listener I think
you're one of the best voices on the
left thank you for everything that you
do
um and I just want to talk about an
epidemic happening in our schools
um I've been teaching for six years now
and I've watched the progression of the
addiction to cell phones with kids reach
a remarkable level it is something that
you know we ask them as teachers we
don't have a universal policy but we ask
them hey put these phones in a bucket
during obstruction time and we're gonna
try to get you focused and they cling on
to them almost like heroin adds yeah and
I I just don't know
um if there's enough national attention
around how we are bringing these kids up
with these devices
um and I just I want to know your
thoughts on how we might approach this
as a national discussion I'm basically
with you as to the level of problem that
this this is I I think it really is an
epidemic I think there's a couple
different things here this is a separate
issue from adult so-called addiction to
social media specifically I think
there's two different things and we want
to make sure we deal with them
differently what you're talking about uh
I I see it firsthand in a lot of my
friends who have kids and from those who
teach in schools I also hear it and
there clearly is something physical that
goes on with these screens even like
with my baby daughter who's not even six
months old sometimes like if she's just
handed to me for for two minutes and I'm
sitting at my desk even if I face her
completely away from the screens she
starts craning her neck trying to get a
look at the screens and we don't show
her any screen so I just basically walk
out of the room
um it does seem that
there is something just physical going
on here and my concern is attention
spans inability to focus inability to do
what Cal Newport calls deep work so at
the societal level or at schools I have
no idea what the solution should be I
know I'm going to take a personal
approach you know and for now it's
basically no screens period and we'll
revisit it at some future period you
know Future Point uh but no I agree with
you it's an absolute epidemic
yeah one last Quick point I did work at
a charter school for a brief amount of
time where they took the phones at the
door yes um and that had a huge uh
impact on teaching and learning it was
incredibly powerful I just don't know if
public schools have the resources they
need
um to it I mean it'll take an army to
get the phones at the door and it's
gonna be a battle and it's and it's
something that the parents aren't all on
board with because they text their kids
in school it's an absolute nightmare
that's what I was going to do which is
I've I've know people who teach at
Charter Schools who have had good luck
with that they even have these devices
that like you hold the phone but the
phone is in a device I forget what the
name of it is you just can't use it
until the end of the day but there is
that issue where for for many kids
parents are relying on that in case they
need to communicate anything in case
there's an emergency or whatever I don't
know how frequent that is I don't know
how good of an argument that is but I
think even parents nonsense it's
nonsense you say yeah it's nonsense it
is so
um anyway I'll let you get some more
calls uh you're awesome David keep up
the great work happy holidays and uh
enjoy the time with your family all
right thank you and likewise uh big big
time holiday coming up here in the
United States let's try Colin from
Oregon Colin welcome to the show what's
on your mind today
uh David can you hear me okay yes thank
you please
hey uh I appreciate the previous caller
I'd like to ask you some questions about
fentanyl okay now is it fentanyl or is
it fentanyl the way Donald Trump says
honest I honestly don't know I think
it's fentanyl you pronounced it
beautifully
oh I appreciate that
um so I read a lot of stuff just like
everybody else does and the reports that
are more more recent are saying well
China's producing Fentanyl and they're
shipping it to South America and these
immigrants are pouring through our
borders right uh bringing fentanyl but
the truth the honest truth is we have
seen fentanyl in all 50 states yes
so it's getting here somehow the thing
is I miss I was misled
um I thought actually maybe there were
some people in our country that were
producing Fentanyl and just Distributing
it what can we do to stop the flow of
fentanyl you know this is a a very
complex issue that clearly is not going
to be solved with a wall on the U.S
Mexico border now it is true that the
primary source countries for Fentanyl
and related substances that are traffic
to the U.S are Mexico and China
um India is increasingly a source for
both the finished fentanyl but also some
of the precursor chemicals
there are seizures at the border but we
need to be looking at ports of Entry
including airports and and you also have
to be considering that if you fix the
issue as it might be seen fixing it
right using the language of the drug war
if you fix the issue of the fentanyl
that's trafficked in
you then incentivize the domestic
production so then you have to figure
that out so I I don't think there's a
simple solution but what I can tell you
is like the issue isn't something Biden
did at the U.S Mexico border
right they're saying that well if we
just close the border right we could
stop the the
um the what's the word the metaphor of
immigrants pouring in do we really think
that immigrants they do it is it I mean
the numbers the numbers did increase
when Biden took over the numbers of
immigrants did increase but of course we
also said we won't separate your kids
from your parents anymore you know yeah
but I think you have to consider with
that Colin is what the oftentimes these
right Wingers cite the increased number
of apprehensions as evidence that more
people are coming in but remember that
those people are being apprehended
there's a different case to be made
which is oh maybe Joe Biden is having a
better job done at the border where we
are apprehending more people and fewer
are getting in now I'm not saying it is
that way but when the right likes to use
just that metric it's kind of it's it's
quite dumb actually to just use that
metric
and I've talked to many right-wingers
and I said you know that they used a
border wall campaign fund to a grift
like a millions of people and raise a
few million dollars and they're like
what and I'm like yeah you didn't hear
about that Oh you mean the Bannon build
the wall thing
yeah well they think that that Trump
didn't get to build the wall and the
thing is he could have and what they
said was that's what they say is like
Biden said no and stopped all procedures
and there's just fence line just
standing by what so I don't is that true
um I honestly am not sure it's hard for
me to keep track of all of the different
claims that that they make but all of
the ones I've looked into so far have
not been accurate but that one I'm just
not familiar with yeah I live in a
pretty conservative I'm trying to make I
try to make middle ground with a lot of
these folks around here and they tell me
this and I think it's hard to it's just
what you when you get Gish scallops when
they're like look at all these and
you're okay I can only take this one at
a time right but the most of the
responses that I get are largely just
like a like a shock like you said shot
out of a cannon it's so many different
discussions all at once like Mike
Lindell it's too much and this is you
know Sam Harris love them or hate him he
has a really good podcast on this where
he explains why he won't like debate
Brett Weinstein on vaccines because he
said the problem is you know these folks
can very easily come in and set like 10
small fires and you might only have the
tools to put out nine of them and they
go yeah but didn't you see that study
from like Bangladesh where they like
Ivermectin cured everything and then
you're like well no I didn't see it but
now you can't respond then it becomes a
mess I think lose
yeah it's not a discussion that's taking
place you're not having a good faith
discussion it's a I have the the whole
alpha male I have to win this discussion
I have to win this argument instead of
maybe understanding you might be
actually wrong about something right
absolutely Colin you could probably said
it any better
anyway sorry I want to say I'm I'm
grateful for your show and I'm grateful
for you uh thank you so much and have a
nice day you too and have a good holiday
and are you are you doing turkey are you
doing multiple roast chickens what are
you doing our family is very diverse
we're just kind of we're doing a
plethora of options I know we're doing
like a smoked mac and cheese wow I don't
know yeah I don't know if you're into
that are you smoking it with cherry wood
or what are you smoking with
oh we have a Traeger um we just you know
it's just a recipe we've never tried it
before but you gotta use you you bake
the thing and then you you smoke it on a
trigger absolutely you're not gonna use
like Liquid Smoke though you'll use real
smoke
oh absolutely yeah good I knew I could I
could tell from just talking to you you
would never resort to that
sir sir I have high standards when it
comes to culinary science
um thank you Colin have a great holiday
great to hear from you let's go next uh
it's great to check in and see see what
everybody's plans are let's go to um
let's go to Ricky from Charlotte Ricky
you can unmute yourself and then I'll be
able to hear you and then we'll we'll be
able to talk and it'll be great Ricky
you are self-muted but you can unmute
and then you will be all good
hey Dave can you hear me I can hear you
fine
okay awesome I wanted to ask you I'm
trying to
sort of digest the
um results from the election and get an
idea of a lot of the meanings of the
results and one of the things I was
thinking about was
the the Republicans underperformance
what does what do you think this means
about
um a lot of the rights uh efforts and
Investments going all in on uh cultural
Wars and uh and especially like a lot of
their
um uh a lot of the Investments they've
made in alternative media seem like
Outlets like the daily wire turning
points USA and
um and and then just you know a plethora
of different like online streamers and
people like Tim Poole and like all these
things are doing like the disaffected
liberal Dancing Yeah and things like
that and seeing that it it seems to me
like I'm just surprised that none of it
has really shown up electorally I mean
is is that surprising I don't think it's
surprising and here's why
um based on what we saw online
it wouldn't have been crazy to expect
Bernie Sanders to win the 2020
Democratic primary if you looked online
you would have thought Tulsi gabbard
certainly must have more than two
percent support
and Bernie's probably going to run away
with this thing and of course that
wasn't the case because so much of of
what voters do
doesn't involve posting to Twitter and
Reddit or whatever the case so sometimes
we we like misunderstand the size of a
movement based on looking at social
media similarly
even though for example in the lead up
to 2022
much of what we heard from Trump and
Kerry Lake and others was about they
stole 2020 and I really won and all this
different stuff
um a lot of Republican voters are not
interested in that and and to some
degree they rejected it right they
rejected J.R Majewski and John Gibbs and
Kerry Lake and Tudor Dixon and so on and
so forth now I think the risk is
some people look at one election and
they take some huge overarching
um uh conclusion from it
and we really shouldn't do that each
election gives us a little bit of
information about a couple of things so
like it's not that the stop the steal
stuff isn't real within the Republican
electorate it's just not quite as
popular as it might seem from following
Trump and so it didn't go that well for
republicans and so the important thing I
think for Democrats to do is to try to
get a better grasp on what isn't working
for republicans and for example it was a
good strategy for Democrats to play up
the the big lies stuff in 2022 because
they correctly assessed a lot of
Republicans aren't going for it I don't
know that there has to be some Grand
takeaway but it's a lot of little
takeaways
yeah no I I definitely agree with uh a
lot of the little takeaways
um uh the themes you know in the in the
results but the I guess the thing that I
I'm just like really interested in is
it seems to me like on a national level
like the Republican politicians have
really like adopted a lot of online
rhetoric and language and you see like a
lot of proximity with what
um you know this this new movement of
like young right-wing conservatives you
know like Ben Shapiro on The Daily wire
and Charlie Kirk and all of them and you
know and they have these things like
they have the CPAC in the uh Charlie
group like has the Charlie Kirk's group
has like multiple events and stuff per
year and I'm like is that is that just
be like is it just they're investing in
all that because they're trying to push
back against the fact that there's this
Rising young voters that are left-wing
and they're scared to some degree yeah I
think they see the demographics they
know that 18 to 29 year olds are voting
pretty left and and unfortunately they
are smart to do what they're doing they
are pouring money into trying to grab up
those young voters and so my concern is
even though 18 to 29 year olds and soon
to be 18 year olds are a huge
opportunity for the Democratic Party the
Democratic party doesn't seem as
committed to pouring the money into
Independent Media shows and events and
this type of thing the right is smart to
do it and the left needs to get on the
ball
yeah
um so you think it could eventually
start showing some electoral effects it
could it could
okay yeah
um well I I hope that uh they catch up
on this because you know I I I I mean I
am glad to see that they weren't able to
effectively make you know trains in the
kids is this number one issue I don't
think anybody really voted on that and
stuff but
um they're clearly like trying a lot
with this cultural they absolutely are
they absolutely are we got to be ready
Ricky thank you for the call thank you
David all right there is Ricky why don't
we go next to Gabe from Louisiana Gabe
welcome to the program
can you hear me yes
Hey so uh I have a question about uh the
Republican response to the 2022 midterms
okay
so I was
very much scared that many Republicans
would refuse to concede however based on
what I've seen it seems to mainly just
be Carrie Lake unless there's someone
I'm not aware of no it's basically you
have like yeah
but yeah so do you have any idea why
they may have backed off from that do
you think it might be because they see
that you know the Trump candidates
didn't do well so they're trying to
distance themselves or what do you think
it's two things I think it's number one
um they saw the trend and a lot of these
people lost and the idea that it was all
fraud even if some Republican voters
would buy it seems like a very hard case
to make because a lot of these were
individual State cases that's number one
secondly I think it's that it's now been
two years of trump and people around
Trump trying to overturn the results and
it hasn't worked and if Trump wasn't
able to do it I can't imagine they think
they will be able to succeed so I think
it's some of them recognize the futility
of it
okay awesome that very much answers my
question thank you so much for your
Insight David I really appreciate it all
right Gabe from Louisiana great to hear
from you let's go to Lexi from New
Mexico Lexi welcome to the program
and Lexi you've got to unmute yourself
you've currently self-muted
and only if you turn that off will I be
able to hear you
hi David can you hear me yes
sorry I was in the process of making
sure I was completely muted on Discord
so you just beautiful at me beautiful
beautiful
um
so I'm a young voter I just turned 18 in
this last June so I got to vote for the
first time beautiful and something I saw
at least here in New Mexico and my
voting basis is
how active especially the older voting
group is just first hand compared to
younger voters and like um gen xers
right
and then seeing in my own classroom and
even in like my parents friends and
everything how so many people still have
the mentality of whatever I do whatever
I vote for it doesn't really affect me
in politics especially when it comes to
National politics so many people just
don't think that their vote matters and
don't really think that anything big is
gonna happen
but I think the reason we've started to
see that change a little bit more with
younger voters is the Republicans
rhetoric where against the lgbtq
community because so many young voters
and young people are part of that
Community yes
um so they I I think it's going to be
hard for Republicans uh going off what
they'll call her a few colors ago I was
talking about for Republicans to fully
grab onto the younger voting base
because they are pushing that issue so
hard I tend to agree with you I think
unless they ease up a little bit on that
stuff they are going to struggle with
the 18 to 29 year old but not not
necessarily because 18 to 29 year olds
are part of that group but to some
degree because 18 to 29 year olds don't
see it as logical to be attacking
individuals who are lgbtq
yeah because even if they're not part of
that group a lot of them have friends in
that group or they know people in that
group and everything so yeah I agree but
my question is how do you think
Democrats can not only start to mobilize
more younger voters but just all the
people who are a center and Center left
who I know who just don't go and vote
because from my perspective I see that
it's much more likely for the people who
are center right and right to go vote
than the people who are Center left and
left to go vote because Democrats are
just so bad at mobilizing and motivating
voters
I think you're absolutely right you know
I I don't have any special insights on
get out the vote this is a known issue
that get out the vote is tough on 18 to
29 year olds but I think the Instinct
you have is absolutely correct the right
is pouring money into it as I talked
about earlier with another caller and
unless the left starts doing it and
activating people with these glitzy
events and wrestling style intros I hate
to say it but the Wright does some of
that stuff because it works and the left
needs to figure out how to do it listen
Lexi I'm gonna let you go because I am
out of time I appreciate everybody who
called in we're going to take a quick
break and be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's get into the mailbag if you have
something to say you can email info
davidpackman.com sometimes we will pick
something from a YouTube comment or a
Twitter message or whatever the case may
be I want to start today with someone
who feels very very strongly
about Donald Trump
even after Trump's announcement that he
is running this individual JR says
Trump's not running JR says he ain't
running he can announce all he wants but
he's ultimately not running I'm so sick
and tired of his big fat miserable ass
enough already either stroke out or have
the big one and die I don't care die old
bastard die already this is very
aggressive when will the Decades of coke
and meth abuse finally get him I'm over
at America is I'm over America is over
it just at least have the dignity to go
off somewhere like an old cat or dog be
your fat old self and croak already
please spare us any more of your ugly
misery so Jr is exhausted by Trump
but I have to tell you I believe that
he's running that being said we talked
earlier in the week about a path in
which a failing Trump campaign
prematurely ends
before the first primaries and we
explored that in detail earlier in the
week I don't think it's completely
implausible one other comment about
Trump 24 from Nathan the subject is
magaga
Nathan says in his announcement Trump
said he will make America great and
glorious again will he Rebrand his
movement to magaga
very good question I don't believe he
will but there should certainly be some
kind of rebranding the current branding
is really not so good on the topic of
getting men out of women's sports as the
Wright loves to say Alex had a really
good thought
Alex said hey David I don't believe
Trump would even have the power to ban
trans individuals from participating in
the sport Association that lines up with
their gender identity
aren't Sports associations private
entities if they allow a trans male to
female to participate in a sport
formally consisting of majority CIS
women that is their own choice with all
due respect Alex yeah this is actually a
very good point so there's two issues
here there's they claim to be about
small government conservatism and yet on
social issues there's no one that wants
more government involvement than they do
the truth is that all sorts of different
athletic organizations have already had
systems established to determine who can
participate and and what does it mean to
qualify to compete as a woman this is
this is not a new issue even though they
want to make it seem like it is it's not
a new issue it's been around for a while
and many of these leagues have already
dealt with it before those running
leagues that have dealt with it there
are weightlifting around the world okay
so it's not not a new issue secondly
they say we want the lightest possible
touch from government
government should only be involved in
anything when it is absolutely necessary
and in the public interest
and one of the things they want to
choose is
who is in which sports league so that's
part two it's not really small
government and number three is
absolutely correct that with many of
these leagues they are completely
private the one area where some legal
Scholars say you you might be able to
kind of crowbar government in would be
when it comes to State College athletic
programs
things involving Title IX and in some
other narrow circumstances but this is
another very good point which is it's
not even clear that legally whatever
Trump imagines he would do on this issue
aside from it being bad faith aside from
it not even really being an issue Scott
Galloway on yesterday's show told us
that in South Dakota they were passing a
law about this and that there is not a
single instance of a quote men and
women's sports that they've actually had
to deal with yet they want to pass a law
about it
um a lot of problems with with all of
this and let's hope
that Donald Trump never even ends up in
the position to do it Steve wrote in
about the fact that all of those people
that travel around the country to all
the Trump rallies they weren't invited
to Mar-A-Lago for Trump's big
announcement Steve writing in Trump fans
from rallies not invited to Mar-A-Lago
David sir I found it interesting when I
looked at the crowd of people that
attended the 2024 announcement at
Mar-A-Lago that none of the typical
Trump fans that we see at his rallies
were invited could it be that Trump
doesn't like to hang out with his
faithful rally goers listen I have said
this before not that we needed more
proof but I have said before
Trump doesn't like the people that voted
for him Trump is a rich guy from Queens
Manhattan spent most of his life
away from the folks that ultimately
became his constituents and trying to be
nowhere near a lot of those folks and
now he has built this Persona where I
mean think of it at age 68 he suddenly
is religious at age 60 80 suddenly
against abortion he likes uh the boaters
of Florida he likes country music none
of it is believable it is all a
character necessitated by the reality
that Trump couldn't win a Democratic
primary because there are some standards
in the Democratic primary I'm not saying
that the standards are amazing or
anything to write home about but there
are at least some standards among
Democratic primary voters among
Republican voters there are absolutely
no standards and that's why Donald Trump
had to run as a republican despite the
fact that he was probably really a
Democrat for most of his life next email
is from Greg and Greg brings up
something that I think is completely
implausible Greg says Trump DeSantis
2024. David I write to you with tears in
my eyes and fear in my heart I'm very
afraid that Trump and de sanctimonious
will make up in time to join together on
a ticket in 2024 with the promise that
Trump will back DeSantis in 2028. do you
see that as a possibility
I really don't you know sometimes we
look at some of these scenarios and we
say statistically there's some sense to
it Trump and DeSantis right now each
have roughly 40-ish percent of support
depending on which poll you look at it's
50 30 or whatever for the Republican
primary the math of it should be
DeSantis supports Trump
on the understanding that Trump chooses
the santis VP then DeSantis has a path
to be president in 2028. the math of it
makes sense what doesn't make sense is
ego and narcissism will not allow it
Donald Trump's ego and narcissism and
maybe to some degree Ron desantises I
don't believe will allow that scenario
to become a reality if you disagree with
me let me know I'd be curious to hear
from you John wrote in John wants to
talk to me about guns
John wrote in saying I own 24 Firearms
many of them assault weapons hello David
I'm a strong supporter of the Second
Amendment I was wondering if it would be
possible for us to have a conversation
quote on your show I don't know why
that's in quotes about what the role of
guns in our society should I'm guessing
it means should be including kinds of
guns people should own including assault
weapons Etc I promise I will treat you
with the utmost respect while I would
consider myself a strong conservative
man I'm glad that it's he's not just
conservative he's strong
I am generally open to other people's
ideas and feel I can be persuaded if I
feel a person I'm talking with can make
a sensible argument my number is blank
hope to hear from you soon by the way
please blur out my number yeah listen we
take calls once a week and you can call
in this isn't exactly the type of call
we would schedule but John I would love
for you to call in when we are taking
live calls and then we can chat about
your perspective on assault weapons I am
curious why someone needs 24 guns maybe
you're a collector I don't know but
that's that's an open question Carolyn
wrote in about an issue with Instagram
and this this is horrifying that this is
going on I've told you about this before
but it's still happening Carolyn says
hey I know you're having you were having
problems with Tick Tock due to malicious
reporting it appears that Instagram may
have also taken some sort of action
along the same lines as I received an
error message on the app stating the
following David Pacman show can't be at
mentioned because they have repeatedly
posted content that goes against
Community guidelines on false content
about covid or vaccines
Carolyn says if it's a problem you're
aware of I apologize but I've been a
member and a listener I don't recall you
mentioning yeah this is this is insane
there's no way to appeal it
Instagram's appeal process so here's
what happened basically we published
videos debunking misinformation about
vaccines
they were flagged by Instagram as videos
pushing disinformation about vaccines
which means no one can tag us on
Instagram when we try to appeal it
there's an appeal process but you have
to submit the videos in question that
caused the problem but those videos have
been removed so we quite literally
cannot file an appeal so I appeal to you
in the audience and really with tears in
my eyes
if you work at Instagram Facebook meta
if you can help with this
I'm desperate for your help our
Instagram is being hindered dramatically
because people can't tag us and they
can't share our content in that
particular way
if you can help please email info
davidpackman.com we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about so
many different things huge announcement
our white paper on talking to family
on at Thanksgiving about things you
disagree about
is now live and available for free we
produced a guide which you can get at
davidpackman.com guide for free I'm I
have nothing to sell you here it's a
free guide people call in all the time
they say David how do I handle this that
conversation
we have like it's like a 10-page paper
got really really good
davidpackman.com guide read it before
your Thanksgiving conversations let me
know if there are things that should be
added modified whatever
free if people like these we will do
more of these guides we have a great
bonus show for you today join pacman.com
to get instant access I hope to see you
there